congresswoman Alexandria ocasio-cortez
confessed open borders are necessary so
she gets her food delivered on time
what we've been struggling with now is
that Asylum Seekers that come to New
York City are legally have not been able
to find a job and support themselves and
the kicker is that so many people are
trying to hire are actually trying to
hire folks in agricultural sectors Hotel
sectors they want to hire Asylum Seekers
so you've got
you've got small businesses American
companies that want to hire
you know immigrants and you've got
immigrants that want to work
uh yeah why do they want to hire
immigrants oh because they can pay them
Dirt Cheap wages and no Health Care
and Biden just shattered his own record
nearly a quarter million illegals broke
into the country last month so it's
clear there is no border security
they're just using the Border as a
vacuum for Latin America and for all
over the world
Biden's confessing too he's not even
pretending he's trying to stop illegal
immigration it's just an amnesty plan
watch or significantly expanding legal
Pathways for entries so businesses can
get the workers they need families don't
have to wait for a decade to be together
I've also directed my team to make
historic increase in the number of
refugees admitted from Latin America
RFK Jr seems to be the only Democrat
trying to do something about migration
he's down in Texas tonight and he joins
me now so you just heard aocn the
president say they're just trying to
match third world workers with American
companies what's wrong with that RFK Jr
it's just a business plan
well there's nothing wrong with it if
it's legal immigration
the problem is the open border is not a
way to do that and I understand that a
lot of the Democrats promoted this
policy at the beginning of the Biden
Administration
out of a humanitarian impulse but it's
been a catastrophic catastrophic failure
it's caused a humanitarian crisis at the
border our border policies are now being
administered by the Mexican drug cartels
we brought seven million illegal
immigrants into this country over the
past three years
we and most of them by the way when I
went down there Jesse we only ran I I
interviewed about 300 immigrants coming
across only two of them the two groups
from Latin America
had any kind of Asylum claims the rest
of them said we're just here to work
trying to bring people here to work we
ought to
right we ought to have an open gate you
know we ought to have open Gates that
encourage legal immigration and make it
an easier path to citizenship but just
to open the borders there's no country
in the world that can do that and to
survive and RFK okay we talked about
Rick Adams yeah we talk about how it's a
humanitarian crisis for the migrants yes
it is but it's becoming a humanitarian
crisis for the American people do the
Democrats in Washington see either of
those things
I don't think that President Biden sees
he's doubling down on this policy he
announced this week that he's giving
amnesty to 470 000 only almost half a
million Venezuelan immigrants
who've come across over the last three
years and this is a really bad message
what that's going to do it's going to
drive a new tsunami of immigration
because people are now going to say oh
you know if we come across illegally we
are going to get a path to citizenship
it's not the way to conduct an
immigration policy it's doubling down on
a very very bad policy as you said mayor
Adams Eric Adams is the mayor of New
York
has that this is killing New York is is
going to destroy the city it is crushing
the social service systems it the costs
so far to New York City has been 12
billion dollars there's a hundred and
ten thousand illegal immigrants in the
city they have nowhere to go they cannot
work uh there it is a disaster for
everybody who lives in the city and now
what this policy has done
is to turn every city in this country
into a Border Town we have to have
orderly immigration in this play into
this country this is not the way to
conduct and what we did today
is the call on all Democrats to unify
with Republicans and independents and
ask President Biden to reassess this
experiment On the Border because it has
been a disaster for our country it has
been and I hope he listens I'm not sure
he will but I really hope he listens
because we need to figure this out fast
before it's too late
RFK Jr thanks as always have a great
weekend stay safe down there hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else